do you have anything you do to get you
out of sort of the industry for an hour
and then come back to it because
sometimes it's social media it's like I
have to write I know it's true it's true
no it's funny because I'm also a
cinephile and I try to watch a film a
day so I'm still in cinema even if I'm
not working on my own thing I'm watching
somebody else's thing so it becomes to
the point where it's it's sensory
overload that's again why I try to you
know travel with these film festivals
because that gives me a break that gives
me a break where I get to be put
somewhere I've never been before and I
get to explore a place a city usually
where it's like it's a whole new it's a
that's my moment of a break and removing
myself but on daily basis I hike I got
but Runyon Canyon which is about you
know a quarter of a mile that direction
I go there with my dogs and my
girlfriend so that's uh that's a nice
break where you have an hour and a half
of shutting off well I have to admit
sometimes I look down on my phone but
yeah that's where we're at these days
these this this this device has
unfortunately made us I think this
entire society have a case of a Dede
because we're weak it's very difficult
to go
more than 20 minutes without looking at
it
your you have this internal yeah I know
I'm sorry have you have this internal
alarm clock that wakes you I got not
this is crazy this is scary and this is
where I think I may need to go off the
grid for a little while but two nights
ago when it was you know that was we're
speaking right now on the Monday after
the release of my film which was on
Friday I think on Friday night I woke up
my body woke myself up at 3:00 a.m. just
to check Twitter that's how you see this
for the reactions I'm getting so it's
something that is very different from
the way you you used to you know get
reactions about your work and it's
something that I don't know whether
that's a good thing
it can't be a good thing if your body's
waking you up to 3:00 a.m. in the
morning you know what I'm saying so it
can be I think it can get a little
dangerous we're all gonna have to learn
how to live with you know constantly
being plugged in and also - there's a
constant state of comparison going on
because they're not looking at our own
thing we're looking at
oh this was said by this actor about
this actor or whatever and we're feeding
into that mindset you know what I know I
did when I did my I don't I think
competition is is ridiculous meaning in
terms of like getting jealous about
somebody else's achievements that you
should I think in this I think in this
independent film community we have we're
all making such different movies it
doesn't matter we should all be
supportive of one another and and be
happy that we're all getting our visions
out there I mean I you know I love the
fact that I I'm making very different
films from you know the safty Brothers
and the guys that borderline for
you know all the other wonderful
filmmakers that you know I was just at
Sundance with this year and we're making
very different movies yet I think we
respect each other's stuff and and like
and and we're just happy that we're able
to all continue down that this road of
like trying to you know to see what we
can do with this generation with with
cinema so you know it's it's uh it's
it's nice to see that it's nice to see
that's why I live in Los Angeles now
because I see this sort of like
independent film community getting very
supportive and growing and here in the
city and and in that sense of community
I haven't really seen for a while we're
nowhere near like the collectives that
existed in like the 70s and stuff like
that or but but it would be nice if we
got there
you